this is a production of cornell
university
thank you thank you so much for the
introduction and um i would like to
thank you guys for having me um
present my research to you um through
this virtual visit
and so um
so i'm at the university of washington
brothel and i'd like to always just give
a little bit of context about
the institution that i currently work
for
um
because most people are usually very i'm
curious about this so the university of
washington has three campuses
and many of you would be familiar
with the seattle campus which sometimes
is described as our flagship campus
um but there are two other campuses one
in bothell where i am
and the other in tacoma
in terms of the proximity um the bothell
campus
we're about 15 miles away from the
seattle campus
which in reality seems close but in
in seattle traffic that could actually
really be about an hour of your time
um and so this is an uh a table with
some some data from enrollment in
fall of 2020. i apologize i didn't
update it for this talk but um what you
can tell from this table is that the
university of washington bothell
makes up about ten percent of the total
uw enrollment
and when you look at the percentages of
um
student populations you will also notice
that uw-bothell is and university of
washington tacoma are both considered
primarily undergraduate institutions and
indeed these campuses were established
to provide
uh more access to undergraduate
education
um
in the seattle area or in western
washington
and so like
most
um
primarily undergraduate institutions we
have a relatively high teaching load and
so in a position like myself as a tenure
track faculty member i teach about five
full courses in academic year and yes i
always have to say full courses because
you know
not
uh short modules within a course and so
that is
quite
time intensive as well
and another thing to take into
consideration is that as a primarily
undergraduate institution
undergraduates are the people in the lab
in my degree program biological sciences
for example we do not have a graduate
program so we don't have
master's students or phd students in our
program
and so undergrads are in the lab
which is actually
presents really exciting opportunities
for them and also for me
um but as we all remember ourselves as
being undergrads in the lab it is a lot
of learning
the the learning curve is really steep
and then the students tend to graduate
right after they become really really
efficient but i've really enjoyed
working with my undergraduate students
and who have contributed to my research
program
and so
my research interests actually stem from
my own upbringing i was born and raised
in the southern african country of
zimbabwe
and in zimbabwe we love our maize we
love our corn it is a staple
uh it's one of our staple crops
and we use it to make saza which is
shown here um
and
and so it's um it's a paste that's a
little bit more consistent than um
than grits for example
and so sata is a staple for zimbabwean
families and we consume salsa multiple
times a day
but like most
african countries or southern african
countries zimbabwe is subject to
recurring droughts
and i remember as a child there's one
one specific drought season that i
specifically remember when you know
our livelihoods were really devastated
and
you know droughts these recurring
droughts not only affect human
livelihood but also livestock and um
and so forth
and so it is my desire to understand the
mechanisms of how we can improve
up tolerance to environmental stresses
such as drug
and so we're all aware of the importance
of maize as an agronomical plant and so
this is an image from
um a winter field nursery when i want to
dance puerto rico when i was a postdoc
and so maize has a lot of uses that
range from animal animal feed a source
of fuel and food
and the united states is the leading
exporter and producer of maze products
around the world
and so has really important economical
um or economical
impacts as well
and so i know this figure is a little
bit outdated this graph is a little bit
outdated but we're looking at corn
production in the united states
over a 10-year period
and one thing that we notice here is
that you have this gradual what appears
to be a gradual increase in production
over time
but you can't help but notice this dip
that happened in 2012 that corresponds
to the 2012 drought season
and this was another reminder that
abiotic stresses dramatically affect
productivity and yield
and this could be different types of
stresses and in this case we're talking
about drought
so again
you know just like
the things i experienced in my childhood
this was a reminder that the united
states that now that i now call home is
not immune to these challenges as well
and so we can't you know in talking
about maize and raises a model organism
for studies um
we also cannot separate ourselves from
transposon elements that comprise a
large part of the mage genome
and so in this graph we're looking at
percent of tes in multiple different
um plant species
and so i'll try to direct your eyes to
the very end here where we're looking at
maize and one thing you've noticed as
that maze and many of you will be
familiar with this that maze the maize
genome
is comprised of about 85 percent um
transposable elements and i think it was
um
and you know so
in a community we are actively thinking
about
how the genome and and the transposons
the protein-coding genes excuse me and
transposons affect and interact with
each other
indeed maize was a pioneering model for
studies in epigenetics
um
and
one of our favorite people barbara
mcclintock
um
made pioneering discoveries in this area
and so
uh maize has pi um been used as a model
to in genomic imprinting the studies of
pyramidation and what is relevant to my
research and my talk is
um how transposable elements were first
identified in this system and
and understanding how they're
inactivated through dna methylation
and so in terms of epigenetic
modifications
that affect that regulator affects
transcription there's multiple types
that could be modifications to dna
chromatin modifications um and
non-coding rnas and rna modifications
for the purposes of my talk i'm
specifically focusing on dna
modifications specifically
cytosine methylations and methylation of
the cytosine base
and so these are modifications that are
superimposed onto
genetic
information that affect gene expression
and ultimately affect
phenotype
so plans have evolved two additional and
now we know there's more um dna
dependent rna polymerases and i'm
specifically interested in rna
polymerase um
and rna polymerase 5.
and so they
are related to pole 2.
and these function
in a plant-specific epigenetic
regulatory pathway
that
functions specifically for
transcriptional silencing
and indeed in maze there are additional
subtypes of these um po4 and pole 5
which increases the complexities
in studying these mechanisms through
using genetic studies as there's likely
redundancy that goes on
okay and so
poll four and pole five
maintain genome stability via an rna
directed dna methylation pathway also
known as rddm
and this pathway is reliant on the
biogenesis and response to small
interfering rnas and so this is an um
beautiful model that you know from a few
years ago that was derived from
arabidopsis that came from
many years of biochemical and genetic
analyses
so this co this model is pretty complex
and i don't intend you for you to um
grasp everything in detail but basically
it um it begins with paul four dependent
biogenesis of small rnas
that are
processed and incorporated into a
complex that involves
pole five
and this
mediates
chromatin alterations and also denova
methylation at target sites
so for this pathway and relevant to my
studies
one
important protein is rdr2 which is an
rna dependent rna polymerase that's um
that functions in creating a
double-stranded rna molecule using a
single-stranded
template that's produced
by pol4
and so this is a
very simplified model from maze
and
and the components that we understand
um from the same pathway in maze
and so one of the genes that i'm really
interested in maze is known as mop one
or mediator of permutation one which
corresponds to an rna a putative
rna-dependent rna polymerase so it's
apologist to rdr2 and arabidopsis again
just reminding you that
functions to
create a double-stranded rna molecule
using this single stranded template
and so in maize monk one is required for
progression of the rddm pathway that
will ultimately induce genova
methylation
and we know that
in using volpon regions we're able to
identify physiological consequences of
loss of
epigenetic regulation through this rddm
mechanism
and so
um these are some images
from the original paper
for the identification of map one
and in this image here we're looking at
a normal maze tassel which is the male
and fluorescent
and in map on mutants we observe a
variety of developmental phenotypes
um and so
in these other three images we're
looking at mutant phenotypes that we
observe that vary for example and so
this is still a this would be described
as a feminized tassel
um a barren tassel and
when you get one of these mutants in the
field you just completely give up for
the day
and so these developmental phenotypes or
defects are consistent but not
predictable right so in a given growing
season you cannot predict which
phenotypes you are going to
observe
and they are influenced by the
environment and this is one of the
things i noticed as a postdoc
how slight environmental changes would
also enhance these mutant phenotypes
another thing to note is that most of
these defects affect floral and
fluorescences
and you can imagine how that also
affects
yield or seed yield ultimately
and so this shows us that an rna a
multimediated
rna
rdd and pathway excuse me is important
for normal growth and development
and so one of the genes that we know is
regulated in a mop and mediated manner
is known as b1
so the b1 gene in maize confers proper
pigmentation
in specific plant tissues
and so in this example again we're
looking at the male and fluorescence um
tassel sorry
and
um we know that and this is a very
oversimplified model but
in mop1 mediated rddm pathway
directs
induces methylation of the promoter of
the b1 gene right in which which
silences transcription of the b1 gene
however in mob 1 mutants we get this
purple phenotype because
with the loss of mark 1 we are unable to
methylate the promoter of the b1 gene
and b1 is then transcriptionally active
in tissues where it's not supposed to be
expressed and so this is one example
of a very
direct
one-mediated
transcriptional silencing pathway but
over the years we now know that many
genes are silenced either directly or
indirectly by a mob unmediated
mechanism
and
previously we also showed that
this mutation at the molecular level
disrupts the majority of rddm
and so we used the malphon mutation to
characterize regions of the mage genome
that were undergoing
rddm and what we were able to determine
is that rdd and loci
were
within 3 kb of the transcription star
site of protein coding genes
we were also able to
look at small rnas and measuring small
rnas
and in this figure we're looking at some
rnas of different sizes
um
in the mopon region in blue here and in
the wild type control which is in red
and we noticed that um the mutant
in the mutant sorry we observed a
significant reduction in 24 nucleotide
small rnas of all sizes
at regions and of the mage genome that
were undergoing rddm
and we also measured cytosine
methylation and so we're looking at
percent methylation
in different contexts of cytosine
methylation
where h
is either an a t or c
and one thing that we notice here too
that you see in this graph is that
it's a specific context of cytosine
methylation known as methyl ch8 that
is affected primarily at
um genomic loci that are undergoing rddm
with very little changes in the other
context of small rnas
okay
and so just in summary we were able to
identify that these
methylated what we call chh islands are
often located at the edges between
transposons and highly expressed genes
and so this cartoon over here we're
looking at a protein coding gene with a
transposon upstream of that gene
and we're looking at cytosine
methylation or chh methylation
at four different positions
off that transposon and we see that the
region that's closest in proximity to
the gene have higher
have more elevated levels of chh
methylation
and so
with years of
data we're able to partition
the maze genome
based on cytosine methylation and what
we
imagine or what we understand excuse me
for to be happening for um in the
context of rddm and so using a variety
of genetic mutants
we and we know that the maize genome
can be partitioned in regions that are
euchromatic in white here
and heterochromatic in red
and at
euchromatic regions
many major genes are found in
proximity to transposable elements and
then with a specific context of cytosine
methylation
functions to establish boundaries
between
gene proximal transversal elements and
these protein coding genes
so
at this stage
we had done a lot of work
collaboratively
to characterize rddm in the maze genome
and um
and during transitions they're always
really great opportunities for you to
reflect about what you want to do and so
as i was finishing off my postdoc and
transitioning into my own research
program i started to reflect about
what my motivations were and my
motivations went back to
my own interest in understanding
um
the effects of the molecular mechanisms
that contribute to that um
that are affected sorry in drought
responses in a way that we can um
um
overcome those challenges
and so my independent research program i
aim to understand how
epigenetic modifications or mechanisms
facilitate growth development and
responses to abiotic stress in
agriculturally important crop plants
and i aim to use an integrated approach
to identify synergy between two
regulatory mechanisms and in this case
i mean epigenetic mechanisms and the
mechanisms that function in responses to
abiotic stress
and i aim to understand how these
networks contribute to plant growth and
development
and specifically in divergent and
related members of the brass family with
my ultimate goal of being able to
manipulate these responses or mechanisms
to improve crop productivity
so for
the next few slides i'm going to or
yeah for the next few slides i'm going
to just describe
some of the work that we've done um and
so here's an experimental approach for
one of our most recent studies
and so we incorporate molecular genetics
in which we can manipulate
perform some sort of genetic or
epigenetic manipulation in this case
using the marpon mutant and subjects
this
genetic stock to some sort of
environmental stimulus
and in specific tissues and in specific
species and then so in this case we're
looking at a malpoint mutant that has
been exposed to
a stress hormone aba
in seedlings in maize
and so we took
seedlings from a segregating family
a heterozygous family that was
self-pollinated
and then we
identified the homozygous mutant
and the homozygous wild type individuals
and so
one would the mutant would be deficient
in rddm
and the wild type individual be
will be um would have a functional rddm
pathway
and we subjected this to an
environmental stimulus and in this case
we used aba in this pilot study and i'll
explain why in the next slide
and so this setup allows us to do a
multi-level comparison between genotype
and treatment
and then we can then further
subject this to
genomic and bioinformatic analysis
and so just as a refresher that aba is a
hormone that accumulates implants under
some abiotic stress responses and so aba
has a variety of
plays a variety of roles in
the life of a plant but
but is also involved in responses to
environmental stress
in which you observe transcriptional
activation of stress-responsive genes
and also physiological responses to
prevent water loss
again i want to emphasize that
aba is not involved in all
abiotic stress responses but we did use
it as a proxy in this experiment to
simulate abiotic stress and so there are
some stress responses that are aba
independent and those that are aba
dependent
okay so with our um
genetic and molecular genetic setup this
allows us then to perform
rna sequencing and bioformatic analysis
to identify
differentially expressed genes
and differently methylated regions for
example
and
with time as we increase
our sampling in different tissues
we can then also start to create gene
regulatory networks and gene expression
networks
and so in one study and this was a
collaboration
with my postdoc advisor
karen mcginnis
and we looked at epigenetic regulation
of aba induced transcription responses
in maze
and so just to describe some of the
results from the study
we took we used an rna-seq approach
to measure the transcriptional
consequences of disrupting these two
regulatory networks again an epigenetic
network and an abiotic stress responsive
network
and from our data in this graph here
we're looking at the number of genes
um in four different
pairwise comparisons
and so we identified about 3 200
differently spreads genes in these
pairwise comparisons
and
and so a specific comparison is
classified here based on color so for
example we looked at wild type
individuals
subjected to aba
relative to control
or we looked at mark 1 mutants
um
not treated with aba relative to wild
type control and so on and so on
and in each comparison as i'm showing
here we looked at genes that were
upregulated and genes that were
downregulated and so the um the first
column for each color would be genes
that were upregulated and genes that
were downright regulated in each
and so we're able to get different
levels of information based on each
pairwise comparison
for example
um
what we observed and what you'd expect
is that like in comparisons in subgroup
one and two
which would be wild type aba over the
control
we identified canonical about stress
responsive genes with some
um
maze
specific
variations
in a comparison between
in groups three and four for example
um this one would just give us
information about differentially
expressed genes and seedlings because
this was an aba independent study
analysis sorry or comparison
um one thing that you does stick out the
most is that the majority of different
express genes were identified in the
comparison when you had when you
disrupted
rddm so loss of mob 1
mutant or loss of rddm
in addition to the stress hormone aba
relative to control
and one of the most interesting
categories is would be analysis in
groups what we're calling seven and
eight
because this allows us to identify genes
that are dependent on rdbm activity
under abiotic stress through a
comparison where you disrupt the
multiple mutants subjected to aba
relative to a wild type individual that
was subjected to aba
so we're further characterizing these
genes but just in case people are
interested
genes that were enriched
in this category
were associated with reproduction
nucleotide binding developmental
processes and transcription factor
activity
and so that leads me to
um
this slide in which
we wanted to further characterize the
functional character categories of genes
that were differentially expressed in
our analysis
and so we performed a singular
enrichment analysis and gene ontology
specifically for biological processes
i don't expect you to be able to read
all the different subcategories i'll
summarize them for you in a little bit
and so in this
image we're looking at
the log 10 of percent genes in each
category
where a deep red indicates that there
were more genes in that category
and
deep blue
means that there were fewer genes in
that category but they were genes in
that category and so
white or missing means that there were
no genes identified in that category for
that treatment
and we did this
and we looked at this in aba treated
wild-type seedlings
and mutant seedlings that were down
regulated and those that were
upregulated
and so one thing we notice is
consistently response to stress response
to stimulus was common to all as these
had all been treated with
aba
but one thing that you would also notice
that sticks out is this unique category
that was observed specifically
in mob on mutants um in which genes
would downward the down regulated
category of multiple mutants and these
genes specifically associated with cell
size growth and
differentiation and
affecting floral and reproductive
development and so this is consistent
with some of these phenotypes that we
observe
and so this tells us that in the absence
of
rddm or mob1 aba induces
um
differential gene expression um with
distinct functional character and
categories and again we're interested in
characterizing these genes that fall
into these categories in a little bit
more detail
as well as transcription factors that
we've identified
so many transcription factors
were
differentially expressed in our samples
and about sixty percent of the
uh
uh differently expressed transcription
factors were unique to the mark one
mutant and so transcription factors play
key
uh
roles as regulators um of gene
expression
affecting multiple target genes directly
or indirectly
and so we looked at the differently
expressed transcription factors in what
in wild type and malpoint mutants
uh green for wild type and purple for
multiple mutants that were either
upregulated or down regulated again
in this we identified some transcription
factors that were unique to wild type
and and some that were common to wild
type and mutant and also those that were
unique to the mutant and again that the
majority of different sea spreads uh
transcription factors were unique to
them mutant
and so we wanted to probe this a little
bit more
because this data suggested that
um
that rdd and mediated responses to
abiotic stress
involve
uh transcription factors to a
a large uh extent
and so
we um we took advantage of this of a
model that had been uh elegantly
described by joe ecker's group
which is
um
through a really extensive study in
which they were able to
position
transcription factors in a hierarchical
network
in which
a
upper level transcription factor
like a
level one transcription factor
will have
affect multiple downstream targets
right
compared to a lower level transcription
factor and so in their study as well
they also used aba and so aba
is presumed to then activate a specific
type of transcription factor
that recognizes specific aba responsive
elements of
a level one transcription factor for
example
and that then
creates that then creates another
transcription factor protein that
activates a level two transcription
factor and so on until you have your
physiological stress response
and so we
identified
um mains orthologs of
the different transcription factors at
the different levels
and
and um again so this would be a level
one a top tier transcription factor and
level two transcription patches and
level three transcription factors and
then downstream target genes
and so in this
image we're looking at
the colors indicate log to
fold change in expression
where a deep red in this case would be
highly expressed genes
and
deep blue in this case would be highly
downregulated genes
and also something to note if i could
draw your attention to the bottom here
is that
if you see a solid
black circle around that that means that
gene was differently expressed
specifically only in wild-type
individuals and a dotted circle means
that gene was differently spread
specifically in the map on mutant
and if there's no border around it that
means it was found common to both
and so one of the things you'll notice
is that um
we have more um
individuals that are um or sorry more
genes excuse me more genes that had
uh that were unique to the mutant as
well
and so then using
gene regulatory networks we're able to
make predictions about what could be
happening and what transcription factors
are affecting which targets in this
pathway
and one thing that we also noticed is
that we did check
to identify that we did identify um aba
responsive motifs
in the majority of these transcription
factors
and so um just for the interest of time
just um i also when i really just
describes
a dna methylation
experiments
and so we did probe dna methylation
using the similar approach again
using
abscisic acid
as a proxy for abiotic stress responses
in the
in the month on mutant and wild type
individuals in this case we use genomic
dna that was subjected to bisulfite
conversion
but i want to mention that this was just
a survey
of what was going on for methylation so
not very in-depth so we used a sequence
capture approach that was described um
by the springer lab
um
and so we're only really looking at
reasons that we know to have been
enriched
for chh methylation in the mage genome
so we're only looking about less than
one percent of the mage genome but just
to give you a context of what we found
if i'm to use the same color scheme
again where
green is wild type and purple is the
mutant we're looking at percent change
in methylation in the different contexts
methyl cg chg and chh
and one thing we notice is that we have
an increase in cytosine methylation as a
result of aba treatment in wild type and
further loss of methylation
in the mutant
and so
this
shows us that uh you know um
epigenetic mechanisms are really
important
um
as a mechanism of response to abiotic
stress responses and as we think about
constructing gene regulatory networks we
never
epigenetic modifications aren't always
included but then this tells us that
this gives us some insights of their
role in that area
we also looked at transposable elements
um
that were
um
and the different categories of
transposable elements you know
differently
you know an rna-seq samples excuse me
and
we looked at the retrotransposons and
also the dna transposons and in this
image
black indicates
the reference genome which is b73 and
then
and the
white bars would be more upon reach and
upregulated genes and
the
past
bars would be the moplan down regulated
and one thing i just the overall
message here is that
in the mutant we see we identify
specific categories of
dna transposons that are um
specific to the mutant
and
jason lynn who's who is a postdoc and
karen mcginnis lab also
um looked at the physiological
consequences
um
in
um in response to about stress in these
mutants
and so in this image he was looking at
um we're looking at in the y-axis we're
looking at days after sewing at
different developmental stages in maze
and there's um just to direct your eyes
real quick um the pink
lines would be the mop on mutant
that is either
subjected to drought or normally watered
and then the blue would be a b73
individual
um
as well as the green would be a wild
type individual
i'm up on wild type counterpart and so
in this study what jason did is
he um
after sowing um he watered the maize
seedlings until they reached a specific
developmental stage
in which he withheld watering
uh again
subjecting these plants to severe
drought
treatment until they reached another
developmental stage in which they endure
water normally until they reach material
maturity
and what we see here is that the
monopoly mutant is delayed in its
recovery and risk
after drought treatment
showing the
role of the smallpond mediated rddm
in
physiological responses to stress
and so
um in our studies we've identified
synergy between these two
important transcriptional regulatory
networks in maze
interpretation is confounded by the
hierarchical nature and cascading
effects of transcriptional outcomes that
that is a part of both regulatory
networks
and because each pathway is dependent on
its own sense and trans regulatory and
regulatory elements
for example
and so we have used
we did use another time course
experiment to identify
more
direct or primary and indirect
regulatory targets
and that
paper came out recently
and um
so characterization of these
complex regulatory interactions
has translational applications and i
want us to be able to
manipulate these mechanisms for enhanced
stress tolerance in venice and other
crop plants
okay
and with that i will end here
i'd like to
acknowledge several students in my lab
who've contributed a lot to
um
the small point aba study including
catherine liu who actually was one of
the co-authors in our research
manuscript and i'll take questions at
this point
okay let me see if any of you
have a question okay
um
does the
mutant uh remark one mutant
in the early vegetative stage before
reproduction
do you hear the question
yes so if i if i heard the question
correctly does it have a
phenotype in the vegetative stage before
reproduction yes
yes a little bit later so at the seeding
stage we don't notice a
phenotype
but we start to actually see um
expression of the
um
of the b1 gene um
during at the vegetative stage and
that's one of the ways that we actually
um
can phenotypically identify
the mutants and also it they tend to be
uh
much smaller in in size and um
really like with really thin stalks
but but at the like in some of our
studies that we do at the seething stage
we have to genotype
using molecular techniques because we
aren't able to distinguish at that stage
i have a question about working with uh
undergraduates how do you uh how do you
deal with a high turnover and also still
make them feel like they're able to
contribute to the research um in a real
and you know
real way
not just busy work
right so
yeah so you know one of the things when
i was a postdoc
you know when i was a senior postdoc
karen mcginnis allowed me to
um design projects for rotation students
and um
and so and i would design projects that
were based on the research that i was
doing and it so happened that rotations
at florida state were about 10 weeks
as life or fate would have it
the quarter system is 10 weeks
how's that for job preparation
and so
that was a great opportunity for me to
um
to learn how to design
projects in short for you know like in
for short term
um
and the thing about it is just you know
breaking a big idea into smaller into
smaller chunks
you also have a long growing cycle for
form corn takes a lot longer to grow so
it's not around
so
um
to date we have been using seedlings
this evening stage a 10
10 day old seedlings
for the studies that we've been doing in
my lab but now now that i want to work
on the real applications right i need to
expand a little bit more
and so um
with that i am transitioning into um
ceteria as well and i'm working with
andre eveland to try
um create genetic stocks in sateria so
that we can which has a little bit
shorter life cycle and
is more conducive to growing in a
growth chamber for example
and also in the seattle area
but yes so far
the seedling stage is what we've been
using
and so we haven't really been going full
season
i see there's a question from ed do you
want to just get off mute and ask me
sure uh yeah so themla thanks for the
great talk and yeah i was
uh wondering do you think you have
enough knowledge of the sequences and
motifs that you could actually pick up
that model and apply it to say the name
parents
and just look through the sequence and
get started giving predictions as to
where the aba responses would would
change
yeah that would actually be really
something exciting to look at
um
yeah so at this point
we have enough data to you know to start
to make some predictions and then
testing those predictions is really the
next
the next level
all right there's an awful question from
lee cass in the chat where do you grow
grow your maid plants sage roman went to
seattle in 1942 but changed his research
program to east
right
so
this is where you know long term this is
like collaborations are going to be key
right um and fortunately the maze
community has been really supportive of
me and you know offering
for me to
you know borrow space in their field in
the growing seasons but again during the
um
uh
so far we've been using
10-day old seedlings
um that can be grown we do have a
greenhouse but you also sometimes use a
growth chamber
but but that does not that is not yeah
it's not sustainable long-term for sure
okay so i hope you can hear me say
thanks so much uh i really was uh
interested in in the
the slide about
aba inducing changes in methylation and
so you may have explained this and and
so um but i didn't quite catch how how
many of those changes were happening in
say the te component versus rd dm
targets that you'd identified previously
or or you know in in the coding
sequences
right so um
one caveat about that methylation study
was that um
was that those were regions that
we already knew to be enriched for um
chh methylation so what we're
defining as rddm targets
and so
um
yeah so those are
mostly enriched for those regions that
were
between
the protein coding gene and the
transposon
so those boundary regions okay so yeah
so they had already been established to
have elevated
levels of ch methylation
okay great thanks for the clarification
yeah thank you
any questions from the audience here
anybody else on chat uh that has a
question or would like if you want me to
ask a question
okay fella i think you're meeting with
the individual people uh throughout the
day do you know about are you meeting
with students at some point today
i've already met with the students so
that was yeah that was a great meeting
yeah
okay great well i guess we'll end early
and give you a break so that you can uh
get your next uh zoom meeting and
have a moment to you know
get a drink of water or something um
thank you so much for joining us today i
appreciate you being here virtual it's a
very difficult way to meet people and to
express yourself and build
collaborations but i'm really glad to
have you here and
thank you and hopefully we'll get you
here to cornell sometime in the future
thank you yes thank you so much yes you
guys do owe me a visit
well well i need to yeah i need to come
and visit for sure
thank you all for attending i appreciate
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu